I get that Vince loves him some POV
shots but as anyone else distracted by
the fact that this wooden floor is
somehow made of glass for the shot
creativity is fine but common sense
tells me the shot of him whitewashing
this huge strawberry preserves spill
from underneath is impossible also I've
never had to clean up human soup before
at least as far as you know but wouldn't
there be a smarter systematic way to go
about this than just sloshing it around
from the middle out wouldn't it make
more sense to work from the outside in
Jesse might panic and do it haphazardly
but definitely not Walt this classroom
is beautiful but completely impractical
as a classroom I have an idea let's make
the entire room an oval of windows so
that no matter where the Sun is in the
sky will be glaring on our face making
it impossible to concentrate education
same is only 0.25 percent seriously damn
I never would have thought that really
because you're a brilliant chemist
studying at Cal Tech man body
composition is literally textbook high
school science stuff maybe he didn't
know is exactly point to 5% but there is
zero percent chance you're this
surprised by it we are point 1 1 1 9 5 8
% shy this seems like something's
missing isn't it is he 21 grams short
because if Sean Penn walks into the room
right now I'm giving all the sins back
but I swear to God if she says what
about the soul I'm adding 15 more yeah
their planning must be goddamn magic he
just put a gun and bones in that bucket
up people soup even if he sifted it out
before the gush flies I have a hard time
believing the pipes would handle this
dump also is flushing all this DNA down
the toilet a good move I understand were
early in Walter's crime life here but
even I know the bits and pieces of DNA
will now be in the pipes leading to this
house forever oh and please don't say yo
you can't that's the owest and also
likely racist
should you be up on that ladder also she
shouldn't be breathing in paint fumes or
picking wrong colors because while this
nursery is hideous I mean unless you're
going for baby green and then you're
spot on also you asked this question
while she's on the first step the first
step after scraping the human goo they
blow up to kiddie pools which they
happen to have readily available and
then spray off the excess gore in order
to what exactly save the galoshes gloves
an apron
for the next craft project why not use
this downstairs toilet for dumping the
melted corpse sludge clearly isn't as
cared for as the upstairs toilet and
probably doesn't see as much usage if it
clogs it would be far less of an
annoyance and if it backs up you won't
horrify a guest with a floating rib bone
also why is this toilet it's right at
the foot of the stairs and the great
wide open to the basement does pop up
think them seriously bring the newspaper
down here every morning to make this
entire space unusable when you thought
about carbon dance ever making grape
soda in class so many flavors to choose
from and with great Balt is a bad
teacher a barn of yours it's gotta be
true but also so do you isn't Jesse's
slip at the tongue something you could
have used as leverage over him instead
telling white this just gives him more
reason to kill you right Cho steals my
morning routine pep speech when I'm
trying to convince myself I've played
enough merge dragons and can't feel my
toes anymore we flipped a coin okay you
and me you and me coin flip is sacred
now is as good a time as any to mention
how great these two are together and how
much better the show is for it there's a
lot to love about Breaking Bad but what
I love the most might be the chemistry
she inferred it huh she strongly and
fernette well I'm inferring by our use
of the word here that you don't
understand the difference between
inferred and employ next thing you know
you'll say something happened on
accident and I will end you
time support stories maybe show them
some autopsy pictures are you trying to
create a true crime fanatic because this
is how you create a true crime fanatic
I'm not saying I've studied best
practices in the world of death but I
would assume that wearing a very obvious
lab coat with a name badge prominently
displayed on the collar is probably the
first nono also screw people who can buy
shoes off the display without issue I
have to ask for my size and then the
same thing always happens first I
decline having my feet measured and then
they tell me that everyone has a foot
that is larger than the other as if this
is the first time I've heard such news
then I say so why don't you sell few
sets with different sizes and then as
they pause to think about it I offer up
the knowledge the tips and balls also
weren't the same size finally I'm left
alone to try on my shoes in peace on an
unrelated note
did you know Foot Locker has a
permanently banned list
constant Creamery yeah yeah well a
little detour come over here and check
out how the other half lives this here's
what we call the Crystal Palace this
scene went to the Vince Gilligan school
of going on for some time seriously I
love me some atmosphere but I didn't
need five full minutes of what is
essentially a glorified character joke
what the hell is that it was the two
major characters from the show just
happen to be in the same place at the
same time cliche that's it I appreciate
what Walter is doing here but aren't all
these things the same murder is wrong
it's the moral thing to do and
judeo-christian principles are just
different ways of saying murder bad did
you really need a piece of paper to suss
that out also you are not a murderer is
not a pro or con it's literally the
thing you are decided if you kill him
you are if you don't you are it would be
like me making a pro/con list for
whether I should watch a movie and the
first con is you don't watch movies one
this is the third time this toilet has
played a role in this episode and I
think it's a sin it didn't get its name
in the opening credits for the omens
work it's putting it heads up josepho be
ins this episode has more coffin than an
overstock funeral home am I really gonna
send these plate pieces looking nothing
like the pieces the plate broke into a
second ago yes because when you're
sending a Breaking Bad haystack spotting
mismatched plate pieces is like a
goddamn needle but this bloody chip you
don't get to be lovingly scooped this
line of wound doesn't suit you get out
before it's too late
these two have been talking for the past
10 minutes and I'm transfixed Cranston
is astonishing dialogue is meaningful
and nuanced and you can feel the tension
leading somewhere and Crazy Eights
saying get out before it's too late is
another reminder that this show was
designed to break your heart from the
very start the fact that they had to
gonads to actually go forward is worth
another cent off but then again how dare
you purposely hurt me Vince
shame on you sure I'm scared he's alive
sorry sorry I had to break up this
incredibly tragic traumatic tension this
is legit tear-jerking I don't like
feelings nose like a Drake Arnor Factory
in here great car new war Oh zippy why
go through the trouble of gloving one
hand and not the other pan why hold
evidence with the hand that could leave
prints
how would he have this view straight
down the highway when he clearly parked
over the median what about the song well
but you need to take care of other
really messy parts the pools of blood
that I've collected you gotta soak that
up it made me more serious why so
serious some dams more than air some
chili look at me it's gonna run look at
me I'm the captain now coin flip is
sacred you've been putting it up your
whole life
I just didn't know it Perry are you in
there be right out
would you know that anybody in my
situation made promises like that so I
can clearly not choose the wine in front
of me truly you have a dizzying
intellect
don't let it shopping strain your brain
no tripping
[Music]
Wendy I'm home